This is a pot of cool water.
And this is a pot of boiling water.
We've all heard the analogy.
Place a frog in the boiling
water, and he'll jump right out.
But place him in the cool water
and slowly bring the water to boil
and the frog won't know he's
boiling till it's too late.
And that in a nutshell is
modern American policing.
It's how we got from here.
Put on his new uniform.
To here.
Now this did not happen overnight.
A series of major historical
events transpired.
Laws were passed and decades
of slow cultural shift
brought us to this boiling point.
They are literally pointing guns.
And now that we're in the hot water,
the question is, how do you jump out?
This is professor Peter B. Kraska.
He wrote one of the most
popular incited studies
on police militarization.
Militarism is basically at its heart,
a problem solving ideology.
It says that the best
way to solve problems
that you have in front
of you is to use violence
and military type weaponry and
the threat of that violence
to solve the problem.
And that's what we're saying
in today's police institution.
Generally speaking police militarization
has been seen as a problem
in developing nations,
but concern has increasingly
turned to the United States
on both sides of the aisle.
Here's a massive study done by
none other than Charles Koch
of the Koch Brothers about this very topic
and why we should all be concerned.
But this is not an
exclusively modern problem.
Its roots can be traced all the way back
to the original colonies.
The earliest form of policing
in America was slave patrols.
The first of which were
established in 1704.
This is historian and author
professor Sally Hadden.
The slave patrols are
what we might think of as pre-policing.
Their job was a combination
of social control
and racial control to
try to enforce the norms
that the white community
wanted to see in place.
They were created to try to
restrain slaves from behaviors
that the white community
did not approve of.
They had guns, they had
dogs, they had whips.
Once slavery was ended across the South,
slave patrols were effectively replaced
by white community leaders
with either police forces
or a little bit later
with vigilante groups,
such as the KU Klux Klan.
Northern troops were often tasked
with policing Southern states
during the Reconstruction Era
and president Rutherford B. Hayes
was accused of using the
military as a political tool
to bust unions, sway elections
and quell civil unrest.
Scores of protestors
were killed and injured
during the Great Railroad Strike of 1877.
The following year Congress
passed the Posse Comitatus Act,
making it illegal to use
any part of the US military
as law enforcement.
How many people are talking
about Posse Comitatus anymore?
It's very irrelevant.
If someone cares about
one of the key tenants
of democratic governance
is a clear distinction
between the military, which
focuses on external threats
and the police, which serves
the democratic citizenry
of the United States and have a bright
clear line between those.
That bright clear line
blurred gradually over the
course of three American Wars,
not those three, these three.
The first point of the frog being boiled
was the social unrest of the 1960s.
As a response to growing
inner city violence,
President Lyndon Johnson
declared a war on crime
and signed the Law Enforcement
Assistance Act in 1965.
A $30 million program
provided police departments
across the country with
bulletproof vests, helicopters,
tanks, rifles, gas masks,
and other tactical gear.
Less than one month later, the
Watts riots shocked America
and left 34 people dead.
Los Angeles Police,
chief William H. Parker
characterize the riots as an insurgency
and to create a paramilitary
response to the disorder.
14,000 national guardsmen
joined the police
in trying to maintain
order on the streets.
Three years later,
the country was in a
state of complete turmoil.
Martin Luther King was shot
and was killed tonight.
The assassination of
Martin Luther King Jr.
triggered riots across
major cities in America,
especially in Chicago.
The show of force was staggering,
10,500 police, over 6,700
national guard troops
and 5,000 soldiers from the 1st Armored
and 5th Infantry divisions
patrolled the streets.
President Jonathan
declared a state of emergency.
That declaration resulted in
the virtually unthinkable act
of regular army troops deployed
to protect the Capitol
and the White House.
Just a few months later
after the assassination of Bobby Kennedy,
protestors clashed
violently with police forces
during the Democratic National Convention.
And all of it was televised.
It was over this tumultuous
period that SWAT teams
were first formed as part
of a larger police effort
to militarize responses to riots
and other types of civil unrest.
Even though that was its genesis,
the real cause of today's
police militarization
was the Reagan, Bush and
then Clinton drug wars.
I believe this program will prove
to be a highly effective
attack on drug trafficking.
In 1981, president Ronald Reagan
signed the military cooperation
with Civilian Law
Enforcement Agencies Act.
The line between the
military and law enforcement
continued to blur as police forces
received increasing monetary
and tactical assistance,
and for the first time SWAT teams
became a regular part of
law enforcement operations.
Decade later, as the drug wars dragged on
with no victory in sight,
president George Walker Bush
launched the 1033 Program.
This cleared a frictionless path
for the Department of Defense
to issue massive amounts of military gear
and battlefield weaponry
to local law enforcement.
It's worth noting that all
this gear was and remains
to this day free to any police department
that takes part in the program.
All they have to do is
pay for shipping costs.
Let us roll up our sleeves to roll back
this awful tide of violence and
reduce crime in our country.
The Clinton administration
expanded the 1033 Program
after a North Hollywood
bank robbery in 1997.
The two bank robbers dressed in
heavy body armor and carrying
automatic assault rifles,
simply outgunned the LAPD.
This coupled with incidents
like the Columbine shooting
and escalated gun violence all around,
made it painfully clear
that the police needed
to be better prepared for the type of arms
that the general public
had easy access to.
We have seen in the last 25 years,
an internal arms race.
We've seen the police arming themselves
and the people arming themselves
at an unprecedented level.
The first plane hit the first
of the World Trade Center towers
at 8:50 thereabouts Eastern Time.
One World Trade Center has collapsed
in its entirety.
One World Trade Center is gone.
The second tower just collapsed.
We will work closely with our coalition
to deny terrorists and their
state sponsors the materials,
technology, and expertise
to make and deliver
weapons of mass destruction.
The war on terror really
created a new environment
for policing, where there
was this tangible threat
that they had to be aware of.
And so under the auspices
of preparing for terrorism,
we saw a real acceleration
of police militarization.
You had all of these police officers
going through training camps,
for-profit training camps
funded by DOJ and DHS and
getting this weaponry.
Since 1990, law enforcement agencies
have received over $6
billion in military hardware
from the Department of Defense.
Between 2006 and 2014
alone, the DOD transferred
600 mine-resistant armored vehicles,
79,288 assault rifles,
205 grenade launchers,
almost 12,000 bayonets, 50 airplanes,
422 helicopters and $3.6 million
with the tactical clothing
to 80% of all the nations
local law enforcement offices.
Much of this arsenal
was transferred directly
from the middle East
into us police precincts,
especially after 2011 when
president Barack Obama
began pulling troops out of Iraq.
And now you see police on a
to wear full battle dress utilities,
to pursue problems with
the militaristic approach,
go into neighborhoods and occupy them
as if they're doing some
sort of counterinsurgency
and fully embrace the military model.
And this brings us to an element perhaps
even more important than the gear,
it's best understood by applying
a classic psychological term
called the law of the instrument.
So if you have a hammer in your hand,
everything begins to look like a nail.
Police departments have the
technology of a SWAT team.
They have the armament of the military.
You're gonna want to use this stuff.
It plays into warrior fantasies,
it gives it imagery
that's really intoxicating
to a segment of the police institution.
What little data there is
supports these claims.
SWAT style, no-knock raids,
have increased by 1400% since 1980.
This is partly because SWAT
raids on low level offenders
are actually used as training exercises.
But the key thing to remember,
it's not the SWAT teams anymore,
it's how the ideology and the armament
and the tactical approach
has now dispersed
throughout the entire police institution.
Don't shoot, don't shoot,
don't shoot, don't shoot.
Reaction to the grand jury's decision
left destruction in the street
of Ferguson this morning.
The grand jury decided
not to charge officer Darren Wilson
and the shooting death of Michael Brown.
Don't shoot, don't shoot,
don't shoot.
Move, move!
It wasn't until Ferguson that
the rest of the United States
of America finally woke up
to the kinds of things that
were going on at policing.
So it came to a boiling point.
In response to Ferguson,
president Barack Obama
issued an audit of American policing
and signing executive order
scaling back the 1033 Program.
We've seen how militarized gear
can sometimes give people a feeling like
there's an occupying force
as opposed to a force
that's part of the community
that's protecting them and serving them.
But his actions did nothing
to curb the myriad other means
of acquiring tactical gear,
nor did it address the larger problem
of militarized police culture.
And what little Obama may
have accomplished was reversed
two years later when attorney
general Jeff Sessions
on behalf of president Donald Trump
lifted the executive order.
He's resending restrictions
from the prior administration
that limited your agency's
ability to get equipment
through federal programs,
including lifesaving gear.
Which pretty much brings us to today.
I can't breath .
George Floyd's killing at the hands
of the Minneapolis Police
Department prompted mass protest.
We don't need more violence.
Move!
Calls for reform from
reducing police funding
to disbanding precincts altogether
became rallying cries nationwide.
I took the helmet off
and laid the batons down.
Public pressure has moved the needle
on this issue, and cities
like Camden, New Jersey
have become representative
of a new community focused policing model.
But across the nation,
the dice remains cast,
and president Trump has taken
a decidedly divisive approach
on the matter.
June 1st finally gave us a hallmark moment
to really demonstrate the
unequivocal support Trump
has been giving police militarization.
Tensions only escalated
after Trump's follow up
and the assault by soldiers
on peaceful protestors.
At the behest of attorney
general, William Barr,
Portland, Oregon was flooded
with unidentified forces
dressed as soldiers.
[Female protestor] What is going on?
Who are you?
Detaining demonstrators
in unmarked vehicles,
and even assaulting peaceful protestors.
This is why I pay tax.
Move, move.
Lawsuits have already been filed
over these arguably
shocking acts of violence
by federal agents against
American citizens.
But that hasn't stopped
president Trump from threatening
further federal deployments
to other major cities,
escalating tensions between police forces
and the citizens they're supposed to.
If you don't move, you will be dead.
Move out of the way.
The frog is boiled, it's not even notice,
the police wouldn't even recognize
the word police militarization,
because it's just something
they are part of and live with,
and they really do scratch
their head often times
as to where this critical
thinking is coming from.